what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I thought about doing like the
origin a maestro Hulk and I was sitting
here thinking I was like man like the
origin of Meister Hulk because the first
story that came to my mind was featuring
perfect and anybody who knows anything
about my stroke will tell you if you
want to read his origin story you read
future imperfect but that's actually not
his origin and it didn't dawn on me
immediately it dawned on me afterwards
and so this video is going to serve two
purposes the first is that it's going to
give us the origin of Maestro Hulk
insofar is like how he emerged the
background story or the things that came
before future imperfect the second half
of this is that this is exile so this is
technically part of the x-men chronology
that we have after the events of house
of M and this will give you guys a
pretty general idea of like what the
exiled team was about and the purpose
that they served so what just initially
does is this actually picks up with the
maestro Hulk's universe which is to say
the universe of future imperfect it has
a numerical designation but I don't know
what that what that numerical
designation is but what we know from the
original future imperfect story and all
we really knew when it was written back
in 1993 I think it was or something like
that by Peter David was that somewhere
along the line there was a massive
conflict that led to the deaths of
almost all of humanity what this does is
it comes back and it says it wasn't just
humanity it was almost all the
superheroes now what this did is it
emphasized the idea that whatever this
conflict happened to be whatever this
war happened to be it was a war that was
basically launched against humanity and
superhumans and so it really just looks
like a thermal nuclear war I mean that's
really all it seems to be and that's
what they said in the original future of
perfect stories that it was just some
giant nuclear war that took place and
ultimately resulted in the deaths of all
the superheroes but there also seemed to
be some massive conflict that took place
and so we don't know who the superheroes
were fighting we're never told instead
all we're told is that effectively
almost all the superheroes were killed
but what this does is it actually
switches to the perspective of Rick
Jones now for those of you guys who are
not familiar with the Incredible Hulk
landscape where there's Rick Jones
there's the Incredible Hulk it's just
the way it goes and it's not because
Rick Jones is like part of the Hulk or
anything along those lines he's part of
the Hulk in so far that he's part of his
origin story and what this does is it
dates all the way back to the original
Incredible Hulk stories by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby I think back when the Hulk
was great but the idea was that when
Bruce Banner and company were going
through and preparing the gamma bomb the
Rick Jones was just some
kid who was basically a bonehead is all
it was he actually wrote out to the to
the testing site and just kind of hung
out there the result was a Bruce Banner
realized that Rick Jones was there he
ran to the testing site which Rick Jones
out of the way and was bombarded with
all this gamma radiation unleashing the
Incredible Hulk persona but following
those events Rick Jones was like the
only friend that Bruce Banner ever had
he was really more of a friend of a Hulk
than anything else and he was really
just like this secondary background
character that just kind of floated
around the Incredible Hulk commit those
who would pop in and out from time to
time it wasn't until the Greg Pak run
the run that we did where we covered all
those Incredible Hulk stories when Rick
Jones actually got a more prominent role
and became a bomb which is kind of a
weird thing but nonetheless this story's
actually told from the perspective of
Rick Jones in the future imperfect
universe to the Incredible Hulk
2099 now here's the caveat to this this
is not the regular Incredible Hulk 2099
those of you guys who don't know mumbles
got all different kinds of numerical
designations for alternate alternate
universes but Marvel 2099 was literally
what it sounds like it's a universe
where everything happens in the year
2099 that's where like spider-man 2099
comes from and like Punisher 2099 and
doom you know and all that kind of stuff
they all have their own stories and so
on and so forth but the idea is that
this all comes out of house of M and
that's why I say this is a x-men
chronology video because the way this
had played out kind of the background to
this particular story is that during the
events of house of M when the Scarlet
Witch had worked reality and gave
everybody their heart's desires and so
on and so forth there was a character by
the name of Kevin McTaggart now kevin
mchale Girt had existed quite some time
before the events of house of M but he
went by the name Proteus and in the main
Marvel Universe Proteus had the ability
to jump from one host body to the next
and he would burn them out and the
reason why is because his power was so
extreme that he could warp reality now
he was warping reality on a very small
scale he was nothing compared to like
Franklin Richards or imagine jasper's of
a marquee of death and Matthew Malloy
he's not even remotely close to how
strong those guys are but he is still
pretty prominent but the biggest benefit
to him is his ability to jump from one
body to the next now in the main Marvel
Universe he had his own stories and so
on and so forth but during the events of
house of M what we had learned is that
his mother more McTaggart was terrified
of the facts you know of her
sensibilities and the fact that he was
burning out bodies
he would burn out his own body one day
and so the goal of Mora McTaggart was to
basically work on a cure for the mutant
gene that would eliminate mutation in
its entirety well the problem with this
was that in the House of M universe
mutants reigned supreme and humans were
considered to be secondary citizens as
to what this did is it immediately put a
bull's-eye on her and her company
because magneto and his forces
considered her to be the most
significant credible threat to mutant
kind because they were working on a cure
and so winter facility was attacked and
when Kevin McTaggart was freed he began
just jumping from one body to the next
well what this did is in the aftermath
of House of M it brought in the exiled
and the exiles are basically just a
group of superheroes myself and Sal over
count off we called me unsellable
because their characters just can't hold
their own comics but they are basically
a group of superheroes who just kind of
travel the multiverse and at this point
when the story's being told they exist
for the purpose of trying to mitigate
the impact of the House of M on other
universes because remember originally it
was believed in the House of M only
impacted the main Marvel Universe it
wasn't until after the house of them
that that was over that we've learned
when the Scarlet Witch said no more
mutants and then set things back to
normal that her her phrase the magic she
used impact the entire multiverse that's
one of the reasons that people speculate
in the old man Logan universe there's no
more mutants being born that's really
more of a fan theory than anything else
Marvel has never actually guaranteed
that but the idea here is that the
x-files at this point in time served the
purpose of jumping from one universe to
the next and trying to basically
mitigate the impact of the house event
the problem with this is that with
Proteus having escaped and with the
exhales learning who produce is they
basically begin to realize the Proteus
is literally jumping to all these
different realities in an attempt to
find a body that won't burn out and when
that happens his powers will just start
increasing exponentially and then he
will become someone like Franklin
Richards or Majumdar's or someone like
that as well the goal is to keep them
from getting to that level now the
reason why this matters is because in
the future imperfect universe Rick Jones
does not know who the Hope 2099 is never
heard of him never seen him anything
like that all he knows is just there's
just this incredible hope like being
that shows up and it's going to be the
way in which they can defeat the maestro
now what this does is it brings in the
origin of the maestro proper and what we
end up finding out is that following
this great big huge nuclear war in the
future imperfect universe when all the
soup
heroes and most all of humanity was
killed B Incredible Hulk actually just
thrived and the reason why was because
he just started absorbing all this
nuclear radiation the side effect to
this is that it drove him insane
but what's established at the time of
this story is written is that this
version of The Incredible Hulk - maestro
Hulk is the strongest smartest and most
powerful Hulk that there's ever been now
one thing to keep in mind is that one
where Hulk had not been written when the
story had been done and so what we're
Hulk as far as we know that world worker
helped form part of the monster Hulk
that we saw later on those are the
strongest versions of them that exists
at the moment so far in the history of
the Marvel Universe but at the time this
story was done the maestro is you know
maestro reign supreme
now of course that begs the question
what would happen if maestro hulk and
one Warhawk fought each other and that
would be amazing you know I'm gonna make
a video on that like if anybody makes a
video on that before me and they stole
my idea I'm gonna make a I'm gonna make
a video on that the fact remains here
switching over to a place called the
Crystal Palace this is not wildly
significant this is just the base of
operations for the exiles now the reason
why this is their base is because with
the exiles operating as a multiversal
group they have to be able to recognize
and see the multiverse and all that kind
of good stuff but also remain unaffected
by it because remember with Scarlet
Witch using her you know reality-warping
powers
if the exiles were residing in any one
particular universe that was impacted by
the actions of the Scarlet Witch who
imagined Jaspers or anybody they would
basically be affected just like
everybody else meaning potentially their
minds would be wiped they would forget
who they were they wouldn't know what
their purpose was or anything along
those lines and so the idea is that
operating outside of all space and time
they're basically outside of any
influence that could possibly impact
them from these people who can work
reality on the scale now at the time
that this story is written because of
the fact of the x-files had managed to
track Proteus to Marvel 2099 to that
universe and then ended up having to
chase them even further they grabbed
spider-man 2099 what they also did is
they grabbed a character named morph now
this is not the morph that you think of
from x-men the animated series if you
remember that far back this is more from
a wholly different reality and in this
universe Morpha is just kind of a goof
and he just plays around and does jokes
and you know so on and so forth he's
really more the comedic relief but he's
wildly powerful in terms of what he can
do not only can he shape-shift he can
basically turn his body into almost
anything he's not invulnerable
he's one
most powerful members of the team
there's also somebody by the name of
power princess now power princess is
basically Marvel's version of Wonder
Woman that's all it was she originally
popped up in squadron supreme and
squadron supreme was basically just
Marvel's version of the Justice League
I mean Hyperion Superman so on and so
forth like the flash and all those
different kinds of characters that's all
they really were that's one of the
reasons why when people read Hickman's
Avengers and new Avengers and then it
was the squadron supreme universe or
whatever that that uh that Age of Heroes
universe was the people were like why is
he stealing from DC well it's been that
way for years all he did was just grab a
team that already existed but there's
also like Sabretooth different things
like that linked from the Age of
Apocalypse universe it's really just
kind of a veritable who's who of people
that just can't hold their own stories
and so the result is that the Exile is
having realized what's going on with the
idea that Proteus has jumped to the
future in perfect universe they also
bring in V original future imperfect
story and what they do is they will just
kind of run over what we've already
talked about so far in terms of how
future imperfect came to fruition you
know where that universe came from and
so on but they also make reference to
the idea that in 80 years The Incredible
Hulk from the main Marvel Universe will
travel to the future in perfect universe
at the request of Rick Jones and defeat
the maestro that's the original feature
imperfect story from 1993 that's where
all that comes from this is a very
dangerous game that The X Files are
playing because keep in mind despite
their abilities and the different things
that they can do they are by no means on
par with maestro Hulk not a chance
so of course picking back up again with
Rick Jones and so on and so forth what
we end up finding out is the extent at
which all the superheroes were killed
and when we say all the superheroes died
I mean all the superheroes died like
Iron Man Excalibur Wolverine was totally
incinerated different things like that
now again we're kind of asked to take
certain liberties with this particular
bit of a story in the sense we're not
given the reason why it is that
Wolverine died Marvel plays a pretty
fast and loose when it comes to his
healing factor but the fact remains you
know with with Rick Jones grabbing Hulk
2099 and just bringing him over to
maestro what we end up finding out here
is that the x-files realized they
couldn't defeat Hulk 2099 on their own
they couldn't defeat Proteus by
themselves and even if the fight broke
out with my sure hope they couldn't beat
him either the goal was to basically use
maestro as a way to defeat Hulk 2099 and
this made perfect sense because you know
all they really did is just show up to
the maestro and say hey look there's
this guy named Proteus
possession of the Incredible Hulk from
another universe he's come here he wants
to steal your body help us beat him and
then that'll be it and of course maestro
ends up siding with him I sure ends up
agreeing with him and saying yeah sure
we'll go ahead and make that happen now
of course this leads into a direct
conflict with you know the exiled
alongside maestro Hawk against Hulk 2099
and for the most part he's able to hold
his own I mean he's doing a pretty solid
job and then we turn around and realize
that this version of Maestro that the
that's that's being fought by Proteus is
not actually maestro instead it's more
pretending to be maestro and so again
it's really just kind of like the
x-files spinning off as best they can
trying to defeat hope 2099 as best they
can and once he's actually beaten
maestro and turn turns against them now
again this is just designed to show us
how crazy maestro is in the sense that
you know with the exile show up and it
will perfectly content to leave and walk
away my show considers them to be a
credible threat now this is where the
Exile is play their role as time
travelers and multiversal jumpers in a
pretty conservative way because they
could easily say hey look like we don't
want to fight you your ends not going to
come from us your end is going to come
from the Incredible Hulk
you know I think it basically just kind
of retreat instead they don't do that
because remember the maestro cannot know
that the Incredible Hulk is coming there
in 80 years to defeat him if he did he
would be prepared for it my show has to
be totally unaware of what a waste form
in the future entry every scenario kind
of playing out naturally and so that's
what the Exile is do they basically just
kind of play on this now remember this
is maestro I mean prior to world war
hulk this was the most powerful version
of the hulk there ever was and so with
the exhales trying to face off against
them I mean it's child's play for
maestro for the most part there really
isn't a whole lot they could do to bring
him down and so what ends up taking is
the combined efforts of Proteus Hulk as
well as the x-files themselves in order
to try to bring him down and ultimately
they're successful but only insofar that
Hulk 20 on and on uses his continually
increasing strength to effectively
overpower maestro now the other half of
this is that where maestro is able to
hold his own this brings in a character
called longshot now long shot of someone
that we've never talked about before
here on my channel and never really had
a reason to he's really a character they
got his popularity in x-men the animated
series but as a comic book character
he's just one of these guys who's just
more or less genetically slash magically
modified in order to have enhanced
durability and agility different things
like that
he was by no means like the most useful
person ever he was really there as just
kind of a way to bolster an existing
roster of the x-men he was still pretty
interesting in this particular story
just because of the fact that where her
deus appears to be getting the upper
hand on maestro and ultimately intends
to defeat him longshot jumps in and
basically begins offering himself up as
a distraction what this does is it
allows morph to step in and then begin
using his ability to increase his
strength to basically try to overpower
Proteus now forces are playing out
exactly as we thought it would in a
sense that Proteus is able to
incapacitate morph and then in turn
basically forces them to switch bodies
and so the result is that he effectively
takes over the body of more leaving the
body of you know Hulk 29 kind of like
this empty husk and then in turn sees
himself as is virtually all-powerful
being
not only is morph almost completely
indestructible in terms of its physical
form but now with Proteus possessing his
body it's all the powers that Proteus
has which is the ability to warp reality
on a minor scale and so at this point
morph is about as powerful as he's ever
going to be and so what this does is
this leads to a continued chase and into
the finale of the worlds who are story
arc from the Exile where they end up
following Proteus and then it leads to
its final fruition where I believe the
Proteus is captured I don't think he's
killed
I don't number off top my head but it
ends up leading to Proteus as defeat for
the most part but with that being said
guys yeah we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end figured out
though this out they're just kind of
like the origin of Maestro Hulk this is
really like a pre lute I guess or a
precursor to the actual future and
perfect story itself but one of the
questions that I've gotten from a lot of
people is how did maestro Hulk get to
where he is how is he that powerful
what's his origin story and this is as
close as we get we don't really get like
a step-by-step guide in terms of how he
rose to power and everything that my
show is doing in the background and the
details and a great big huge war we
never get any of that stuff instead it's
really just kind of this was being a
closest thing we get to an origin but if
you guys are new here to come as
explained to make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you